[Music]
gonna talk about
doing some mobile devops on gcp it's a
bit of a unique
uh talk that i'm kind of using
some of the tools here to do serverless
uh builds of android apps and
distribution
i actually will show some code and and
whatever and
um if that's what you're here for that's
good
might be one of the more technical talks
i'm not sure
so the first thing to get started is i'm
going to talk about our little
application
i've built a little application that's
going to take the world by storm not
really
um because i'm a developer and an ops
person not a
designer um some of the gui is not that
fancy
um but just built a little note-taking
application and the idea is we're going
to simulate
we're going to build this application
and uh continually
iterate on it make changes to it and run
it through a devops pipeline and
and see what happens so
little idea this is the sort of
sad gui that we have going on we can
take little text notes
and we want to add image notes to our
application but they're not done yet
so we're going to merge a feature and
see what happens hopefully you all could
see the text well enough
if you look at the bottom there's like a
little terminal window
an android studio so not a whole lot to
see here
but what i'm gonna do is try to merge a
branch
um a feature branch
in here and just go ahead and
i'll make sure we've got lots of changes
i guess it auto merged and so um
i'm going to go ahead and push that code
up to
the repository
wi-fi is getting slower by the minute i
guess
as people arrive but there we go so
that's all i'm going to do
on the application uh for now
i can show it to you as well it's just a
little
note-taking application you can add text
note
create a note you can edit a note
everything's stored in firebase
um and that's sort of
how it works
right all right so now let's talk about
devops for a minute
um you know some lovely quotes here
um devops not a goal but never ending
process
um it is how sort of most of us by now
in the past like three or four years are
used to working
we want to get stuff features in in the
hands of our
testers or our constituents in the
company
and get iteration faster find the bugs
faster
shorten the loop
and so in this in this what i'm going to
demonstrate is
um a dog fooding
sort of pipeline where we're basically
we're building and testing internally
developing pushing stuff to the
repository and then sending out uh
apps to our dog fooders but dog food
means that google is
sort of folks internally testing our
applications before we release them
which i think is a fairly common common
term in industry
and so with mobile devops is a little
bit
funky right because we have unlike
web we've got to like sign this binary
we have to create the binary we have to
sign the binary we have to get
the binary to the users and they have to
install it from somewhere and there's
lots of
uh extra stuff going on there that's
not like web we can't just sort of build
a new docker container and launch it
into kubernetes we have to
actually physically deliver a binary to
the mobile user
but we can still do that using this
fun new product old product renamed
product
called cloud build which is originally
uh termed container builder
and meant to be used to build you know
docker containers and
and maybe you know deploy them to
kubernetes and things like that
um it turns out what we learned about
cloud build is that we can build
anything um and the community
sort of taught us that the most i mean
that
there's a cloud builders repository
which i'll show you
that has many different types of
builders for cloud build
but back to mobile devops so this is
sort of a flow
for mobile devops right we trigger some
build we test the build
at least a smoke test on the build and
uh distribute that binary and then maybe
we
monitor for crashing or other analytics
so it starts with developers you know
hopefully
it starts with a repository we're all
putting our code in i think that's
pretty
um pretty known commodity nowadays but
um if you're not using a source code
repository you probably should look into
that
um and then we we're gonna
trigger a cloud build process and
these are the sorts of these are the
repositories currently supported by
cloud build you can
use uh google cloud source repo
which i'm using here github or bitbucket
this is what it looks like to create a
build trigger it'll there's
basically three steps you pick out the
the source control repo you're using you
select the specific repository and then
you set up your trigger
when you set up your trigger you can
pick out uh
a branch you can obviously name your
trigger pick out a branch
and uh
or tag so you can trigger based on tag
i'm using a branch here kind of all the
git flow
um but you could easily just as easily
use a tag which might actually be a
little bit
uh better for your specific case and
this is how you trigger the build which
is what i just did
so building the binary again we're
triggering
uh a build in container builder
or cloud build rather i'm going to mess
that up a lot
and that build is described by this
funky magic file called cloudbuild.yaml
and that is what describes every step
that you want to take just like you
would
in your you know if you're in jenkins
and you have like a list of steps
you'd have that this is the description
of the list of steps
that the that the cloud build will take
and in order to build your binary and
test it
and do whatever else you want to do
and in this case we're going to
push source code and the
steps are going to be described in the
cloud build yaml
and after the the result of our cloud
build is going to be
a distribution through fabric or
crashlytics beta
which is going to end up emailing our
users about the new
uh application
that slide didn't show up right um
sorry okay
so the cloud build workflow is
a again a bunch of steps that operate on
your work
space so when that trigger happens cloud
build pulls the source code
and puts drops it all in a workspace
directory just like
jenkins that probably sounds familiar to
anybody who's used jenkins
and then it runs a bunch of build steps
the magic
um the thing that's interesting about it
is that all of those build steps are
containers
and the commands they're in are sort of
contained all of their dependencies are
contained in docker containers and
images
and so in this case we're doing a gsutil
copy stuff from cloud storage
an android build another
test uh using the gcloud command
and some more android build and that's
all
um all each one of those steps is
another is its own docker container
so you're actually calling docker run in
order to complete that step
in the workspace
and like i said before there's there's a
rich set of those containers
in the community site you can find
you know stuff the android containers
the one i'm discussing here
uh which is contributed by me but um
it's open source so if you have like
edits and
and pr's you can issue prs to it but
there's
as you can see a ton of different uh
containers for for doing builds and
deployments there's one for
for instance uh create you know gcloud
can you can create compute instances and
everything like that um
there's one for kubectl if you're
deploying um
you know kubernetes manifests deploying
kubernetes infrastructure
um and there's some there's one there
that's called the dataflow python which
is you can imagine is meant for uh
setting up a data flow job
so there's just lots of possibilities
so in using the android builder you what
you're going to do is build
the container that's going to
run the android build right right so
it's going to have the gradle
and java sdk and the android sdk
and in order to build that up what we
want to do is we want to build
a container that's lean relatively lean
so we're not
um you know we don't want to necessarily
include every android sdk
from the beginning of time to to to now
in that docker container because it
takes a really long time
to pull that from the registry so
in order to sort of semi-customize and
package an android builder for your own
needs
you edit this packages.txt file
which specifies all the packages you
want in your android
builder and every every time you use the
android bill you can
you can change or every time you create
a new android builder you can change the
packages you're using now
the android builder also uh requires you
to supply your
your license key from your workstation
so
in your in your android sdk home
you're going to have like a licenses
directory so you can supply your android
sdk license from there
as a build substitution in in container
builder i'll show you that in a minute
but so each of these would have to have
the eula already accepted
and then the license key hash that you
supply to
container builder will will already know
that you
have accepted the license and will con
continue the build
and so after that this is sort of the
the steps you you clone the repo
you create the packages uh
text file in that directory and then you
submit the android builders cloud build
yaml
file which is going to build a container
in your
google cloud container registry
that's going to have the android builder
piece and you can just go ahead and call
that from your app's build
which i'll go through
so that's sort of the three steps
and then you'll have the result is you
have this
android builder in your registry
if you want more information on the on
the android builder and
like more specifically there's a
document
drafted by me on creating this pipeline
in more detail on our website so you can
you can hit up this
document and it goes through all the
steps for setting up the android builder
so you don't have to sort of remember
everything that i'm i'm saying here i'm
just trying to
give you sort of an introduction
but here's some more details that you're
probably looking for
so in getting more detail about
you know what we need to do to build the
mobile app we are going to need to sign
the android application with a keystore
file right everyone
who is an android developer probably is
familiar with that
and so the way we approach that in this
is we just go ahead and copy all the
signing information to a storage bucket
and that storage bucket will only be
accessible from the project
that you're using to build and you you
could secure that even further with with
key management
but sort of out of scope here
you copy your fabric secrets up to a
different bucket or the same book
bucket and
you uh there's a extra little
optimization here called the build cache
which sort of tries to optimize the
dependencies for gradle so it's not
downloading the internet all the way
from the internet but maybe downloading
the internet closer
closer to where cloud build lives um
and then we move on for our test
items another thing to to note here is
is the arguments in in the each one
those are actually arguments to the
docker run entry point
and you can change the entry point none
of these actually change the entry point
but you can change the entry point on
these containers
to just sort of execute arbitrary bash
as well
and and just and still have for instance
let's say in the gsutil i want to just
do
arbitrary bash i can add an entry point
in there
run that bash but that bash still has
gsutil in the path
for that command so that bash command
can can call any of the
dependencies from the gsutil container
for instance
um so this is sort of how you put
together a build the other thing to note
here
is the substitutions we have
any of these shell variables with with a
underscore in the front is what we call
a substitution
in cloud build and what that is is a
value you supply when you configure
the build trigger so you can update uh
you can
basically parameterize your build so the
signing api secret bucket path is
where to find fabric.properties in
uh cloud storage it's actually a gs uri
gs coolant slash uri uh the license is
whatever you copy and paste it in for
the license
there's a new version pending by the way
where you can copy all of your android
licenses to another bucket and
use a bucket reference instead that's a
pr that's been submitted and
currently pending and then
another parameter to mention here is
wait
for wait for is how you uh
wait for other things so you need your
signing files obviously before
you build the uh distribution uh
version of the app and so you you're
going to want to wait for the
that copy to complete before you build
the the distribution file
also you you need your
well i'll have to go on to the next
slide to
show more dependencies but you get the
idea
so after we've built the binary so we in
this one we build the debug
version of the binary and then we're
going to test that debug version
with firebase test lab which is a
service that we provide that firebase
provides that has
actual physical devices in a data center
that you can run
both robo test and functional tests on
this pipeline
specifically deals with robo tests but
you can also create espresso
record and create espresso functional
tests
and run those tests on on the devices in
the data center
so it lets you uh run detailed tests and
you can
you can see the results and um
add workflow and etc etc
oh yes let's let's take a look at uh
um the devices
okay so here's a i pulled up a list of
devices recently
um from test labs so these are the
devices you can actually
uh run your functional and robo tests on
there's quite a few of them
some of them are virtual you'll see but
most of them
the vast majority are actual physical
devices that your apk will be loaded
onto
the debug version of the apk will be
loaded onto and test it or the test
abk as well if you're using uh espresso
switch yeah and so here's our
our workflow again
okay so the test lab build set step is
interesting so
here is where i had to use the bash
notion of you know i'm running gcloud
but i'm going to wrap it in some bash to
make sure because
test lab command in gcloud doesn't give
me a good
status uh process exit code uh when test
passer fails so i've added some
fanciness here to to check the whether
the test
passed and there's a grep statement
further down
but you can see more of the
[Music]
the weight for up here in the build uh
so you can see some more of those wait
for argument
and this is sort of like some
screenshots from a robo test i can
actually flip over
to the other laptop and show you
some of the output of a robo test if
you're
interested
so here you can see this is some of the
flow of uh
the robo test is kind of like a a random
touch and type test and you can see i'm
using firebase auth i know this is a
little small
i can get into some screenshots
but i'm using firebase auth here
which uses google sign
in and actually this thing comes up with
its own google account and signs in
to the app and then starts uh
touching different uh
aspects of the app to see just to see if
anything crashes
right so let's say like this create
button was
enabled in here then when the robo test
hit create with an empty string it might
have like caused the null pointer
and if that happened the test would have
failed
so that's and you can also get a video
recording
of your of your robo test so you can go
through
and see what the the automation did and
this is actually on a on a pixel
yeah so it's getting the oauth screen
and then saying yes and then
now it's got the it open it's a little
flickery with the video but you can see
sort of what different screens it's
accessing and
and all of that trying to sort of it's
sort of like a uh
a blind person just trying to break your
application
that's the best way to um
describe it
good flip back
so the rest of the uh build
is trying to uh distribute our
assuming a test the test pass right
assuming there's no failure in the robo
test we're going to want to
send it out to dog fooders for the folks
internally for
further usage um and so that's what
fabric crashlytics is used for and this
is
in in this case i'm using just gradle uh
a gradle command for that you can
actually use fast lane
here um but i you know android
developers
still like gradle i think some are
converting to fast line i'm not really
sure
but this is suffice to say a gradle
implementation so
a couple things to note in the in this
part of the
uh build is that um we're wrapping the
gradle
command with a script that does like
that fancy
uh grab the cached jars from the storage
bucket
and it copies the licenses over that you
supply
the other things you see here are
substitutions
so the build type is the beta
build type in this case and the email
distribution group
is the the set of folks in fabric where
i want to email the
build to and the
um upload
distribution build type is the thing
that actually uploads
the apk to uh
fabric or crashlytics and then once that
is uploaded once that's completely
uploaded your users that are
your testers will get an email notifying
them that there's been an update to the
application and so this is sort of what
that tester ui looks like you can add
emails for different applications you
might have
and uh pick out which of those groups
you want to email your results to and
you can have different ones maybe you
have different build flavors or
different build types
depending on you know who in the company
you might have some that just go to
developers
some that go to qa after that some that
after that might go to
product managers and then maybe finally
the whole company so you can
you can really like granularly adjust
that
finally what we do here is
this is crashlytics and this is actual
bug that i had
in the code it's it's hard to see the
stack trace the kotlin stack trace but
i had a bug with my firebase access
and this was one of the notifications i
got uh from
from crashlytics of the crash um so you
can once this
this thing's out in the wild uh or out
to your users depending on who they are
you can you can monitor for crashes so
this is sort of like a full
serverless pipeline where you know
everything is done using
managed services there's nothing here
that's sort of
an online thing you have to keep
up and running there's no sort of
jenkins server there's no
um kubernetes cluster to keep up and
running there's
there's nothing to maintain it's all
sort of when you submit that new cloud
build yaml
it boots up that container and starts uh
running all the docker commands so
that's sort of the use case here
just the minute i'm going to
right so a few minutes ago i issued a
build and
we can see the results of the bill it
was successful
and this is sort of what the output of
our
pipeline looks like here you can see
each command
and so this is running a
a ubuntu is a just an arbitrary
shell running container so if i use
ubuntu i can just
call like make dir whatever stuff like
that
i've got a copy licenses step and i can
just page through here i'm not going to
go through every
everything the test lab one is
interesting you can see that this one
takes
a bit of time five minutes to complete
which is why i do that at the beginning
and then wait until till it finishes
um and you can see finally that um at
the end of this
there's a whole nother build and it's
finally uh
at the end it finally sends it up to
fabric so there's actually two
gradle builds that happen in here the
first one is a debug build for the
robo test and robo test takes the debug
apk and does its testing on it and then
the the finally
it's pushed to fabric and then from
there
um i get an email
hopefully if i can get my beach ball to
stop
there we go um i should get an email
to my user i'll just go on the
um oh i should have got an
email here interesting maybe i'm not
sending it to this one
um
okay
yeah so from there my users would get an
email assuming this guy's a tester maybe
he's not
not sure um
should have one on my phone
okay i have one on my phone um
let's see if like is it just this one
just pull this out
oh here
so yeah uh oh can we do this
what's that oh you don't have it
oh okay um
well let's it would it work if i just
pull
pull this out and put it here
mei and they're
not really connected in android before
anyway on my phone if you're really
interested i have a
an email from fabric with the new
version
and uh we can also take a look at the
the robo tests that occurred hopefully
right so this is the last set of robo
tests that just completed
[Music]
and
right so they look pretty much the same
as the other ones
um but you can see that this one just
happened about 20 minutes ago
and yeah so
that is in a nutshell how to do
serverless managed devops with android
on gcp it's cloud build um
plus uh firebase test lab
[Music]
you